quindi valentini a schermo intero
buffamente vuoi
in tutto il video vedi tu non pupa di
troppo
gli agenti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono felice oggi siamo su
una reaction che probabilmente e ve lo
dico sul serio è la reaction più
importante da quando faccio video ho
collaborato da pochissimo con il buon
master cast nel caso non lo conoscesse
vi lascio il suo canale in descrizione
ma non è solo questo il fatto perché
questa collaborazione è stata talmente
potente che va fatta una reaction io
questo video che abbiamo fatto le
masterclass non l'ho ancora visto e
conoscendo le doti e i poteri che ha il
presidente so che questo video tra
incredibile quindi voglio vederlo per la
prima volta con voi ragazzi quindi
questo video che abbia fatto punto io
mastercard l'abbiamo registrato tre mesi
fa tre mesi fa cioè montare un video in
tre mesi l'unica volta che ho fatto
progetto del genere stato quando è
uscito che in terapia o che non ho
montato io e neanche massa che prova
quindi non so veramente che cosa
aspettarmi tranne di tutto quindi
facciamo che partiamo con questo video
non avete tre mesi di attesa sono tanti
ragazzi ci siamo mammamia questo ho
passato 3 2 ho sputato 1
ok già partiamo come un film quindi mi
aspetto di tutto
mi aspetto di tutto
[Musica]
cosa va al cinema siamo dolby surround
let's go con la sera vsc
[Applauso]
bellissimo il titolo camera mia
fantastico
ovviamente parlerà di naruto
[Musica]
la mia sveglia non è realmente alle 10
55 ovviamente fake
o dimmi tutto ma poi un pupazzo cav h
[Musica]
le migliori di recitazione comunque
prossimi laghi in terapia ancora
pubblica
[Musica]
sassi così
mamma mia
complimenti hai vinto alla lotteria del
sasso come premium potrai imparare la
tua mossa di dragon ball preferita
la donna che
se in ritardo ma edizione io la metterei
sis ho schiacciato si no
praga il caso di crash bandicoot
quanto fatto nei bellissimi scatti
uscito esattamente quello che immaginavo
siamo usciti a temi 29
l'effetto di crash medico di far
sballare ragazze incredibile sono il
matrix questa struttura
credo
e che fai non la ferri la mano del
presidente speriamo però guarda davvero
mi piacerebbe tantissimo però sono in
mega ritardo devo
sta vedendo
cosa vedo un minuto 6 ora è fuori ok ad
ora insegna milan per energetica
ma no al pupazzo ancora lì dalle
tavole vola tamarrata la volevo la
volevo
e va bene precedente ne sa ragazzi
[Musica]
la donna
quando ho fatto bene ragazzi
[Musica]
camerale
più
c'è da ragazzi dai ragazzi
[Musica]
no
guarda che roba incredibile sto vedendo
storia essere
niente sulla repressione
si vabbè dai
no è incredibile ragazzi veramente
ma poi tutto questo noi l'abbiamo girato
in tre metri quadri come come ha fatto a
fare questa cosa non è possibile
ve lo giuro eravamo veramente tra metri
quadri non sto scherzando come diavolo
come è possibile
basta al conte loro si sarà sicuramente
persi dai ragazzi
comunque meno male perché mi stava
iniziando a preoccupare parecchio
ma scusami sono tuoi sì perché
dovrebbero farci del male
beh basta
a caso il sasso sta sempre bene va bene
ecco la facciamo la vigata ragazzi ma
facciamo una figata
tra poco
all aquila ragazzi
cazzo parli
che sta vista
dai sogni pensieri
voglio vedere come è venuto ragazzi vi
prego
io non so cosa dire
cioè
incredibile giorgio fosse così
se alberto
lo sai
per questo la risposta per questo
io ero io sono allibito di questo
ragazzo mi pare veramente
impressionato perché l'inter
un po mezzo appassionato
ovviamente non lo so fare
[Musica]
madonna
ma chi è
altro che e vegeto
ma anche
tra l'altro indossare con la maschera è
stato un casino perché non mi stava ei
sono caduti questi
c'è la dovuta tenere con lo scotch con
un casino che è venuto mia opera molto
più potente
[Musica]
può fare solo questo quando mi chiedono
di fare qualcosa come scelta del
personaggio
però veramente veramente
incredibile
[Musica]
civile in cui vivere comunque io ho
conosciuto tutto il gruppo quasi tutto
il gruppo d di basket caso sono tutti
ragazzi veramente
pazzesco non sa fare il proprio lavoro
nella maniera che c'erano politi
giuridico dall'altro.poco senti
veramente non so come scusarmi per
evitarlo non mi succedeva una cosa del
genere poi senti ma cos'è che volevi
propormi
hai presente giu
scusa latino un secondo progetto
pronto
a sì sì no no che non gli autori
ma quando ok va bene ciao ciao
guardare scusami ma veramente progetto
bellissimo proprio come dovrei andare mi
di merci grazie grazie davvero bene
oggetto di ordini
loro
[Musica]
quando fai terra andavano
nova bernicchia che figata sto vedendo
[Musica]
ecco
stando
pesa la mia macchina effettivamente lui
[Musica]
sì
assolutamente
ragazzi dobbiamo farlo sas raga dobbiamo
fare noi dobbiamo farlo
ermanno per la supervisione
[Risate]
bellizia annuncia ermanno ermanno
conoscete ormai cioè che non lo dico
richard evans jade vuol dire che è un
figo
è un figo sostanzialmente quindi ragazzi
questo era chiave a me anche alla
collaborazione con io comunque seguo
oltre che io chiudere anche i pooh per
quindi conosceva master cast da una vita
e mezza pre video del signore degli
anelli poi contattato trama fine ci ha
messi d'accordo e io credo che sia
veramente un ragazzo talentuoso cioè
secondo me ce l'avete vista incredibile
far parte di video del genere è
veramente bello mi piace partecipare a
progetti che di questo tipo che mi
interessano e stato fantastico mi sono
divertito un sacco ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale
passato ovviamente la qana di master
cast è andata a vedere ovviamente camera
me hd video originale quindi sembra
reaction e lasciate un commento anche
risotto perché supportiamo quel video
così almeno se va bene e faremo anche
quello
però solo se supportato a supportarlo
niente ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
appunto iscritti al canale sotto questo
mi piace anche visto chalco minuti
prescrizione se ne sono infischiati e
noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video sas